you additionally audition for Augustus
in this film but what is it about Isaac
that really connected with you you know
it just you know boy it was basically
the book was so good in the script was
so good it was like everybody in the
world was clamoring to be a part of this
movie and it's it's mainly because John
you know John doesn't write sick people
or sick people he just wrote three you
know hazel Gus and Isaac and obviously
the adults too but I mean I'm talking to
the young parts that he wrote three
great characters who happened to have
cancer on top of it you know and what
was cool about Isaac was that he dealt
with his pain using humor and that's
actually how I dealt with my pain a lot
and I guess through doing this movie I
realize that maybe it's not a negative
thing maybe it's actually a positive
thing that you know dealing with pain in
that way yes Isaac is my favorite
character in the film he has these funny
moments I'm being serious yes he's funny
moments because he's real angry moments
as well but in the next film John Green
is kind of involved with Paper Towns
you're gonna be playing the lead what is
it about Quentin then that you connect
with Quentin is a really sort of
character you know I haven't like
totally started to break him down and
work on him Tom but you know that I
guess John's just creates great
characters you know and I'm so and and
Mike and Scott are doing the guys who
wrote fault are gonna write this one too
and they're amazing at taking you know a
novel and streamlining and streamlining
it and kind of bringing it back to the
movie reality and so the characters
really cool because he's like it's kind
of like a badass like kind of a badass
detective even though he's like in high
school it's really cool yeah I haven't
done interviews for it yet so I haven't
like I'm just I'm just so excited to be
part of it yeah I'm really excited to
see as well if you got any thoughts he
lights he casters Margay I mean there's
so many good actresses that they're
talking about and I know it'll be
someone great I don't know I don't have
no idea who's gonna be yet
I'm waiting to see yeah yeah no go sit
for me there then finally one question
then why do if I knew I would tell you
one final question and why do you think
the Fault in Our Stars has connect with
people around the world in such a
massive way I think is just honest you
know John doesn't write down two
teenagers he he treats them series like
with a lot of respect and he does that
in real life too when we go to me with
him he's so kind to them and and it
shows in his writing and and I also
think that it's you know somebody came
up to me at the end of the movie they
said I could at the end of this movie I
called everybody I loved and told them
that I loved them well that's perfect
that's exactly what this movies about
you know it's about taking in even in
the face of tragedy like cancer and and
death and it's about calling everybody
you love and telling them that you love
them yeah always always always squeezing
the boob always
you